powering your job search with a cloud
talent solution job search API lets you
start getting quality results
immediately however there are plenty of
ways to tweak search requests to match
any business needs let's look at some
configuration parameters you can apply
and test when making a search request to
make the biggest impact on the number
and relevance of jobs returned when
someone does a search let's look at two
parameters you can configure when making
this API search request enable
broadening and disable keyword match
enable broadening does exactly what it
sounds like it broadens the search
results that get returned it does this
by relaxing the restrictions on location
and job categories this is a binary
property for the search so it's either
true or false and defaults to false if
you don't set it yourself setting it to
true will give more results to a search
query but may start to return extended
results that aren't an exact match for
what the user searched for don't worry
the most relevant jobs will still appear
first the next property is disabled
keyword match which is another binary
property that tells the search request
should return additional jobs through
keyword matching when set to false
additional job matches that aren't
deemed relevant by the ML algorithm but
do match the search query string get
returned
just like with enable broadening
disabled keyword match defaults to false
and any additional results will appear
lower than those most relevant let's
look at what happens when you use enable
broadening and disable keyword match
together this quick table gives a
general idea of what users will see in a
search result based on these parameters
again the most relevant search results
are always returned first without
choosing anything a default search
request has enable broadening and
disable keyword match set to false this
leads to the most relevant jobs being
followed by any jobs that match the
keyword search if you change disable
keyword match to be true but leave
enable broadening as false your research
results will include only machine
learning recommended results since
keyword matching and broadening have
both been turned off this means only the
most relevant jobs are displayed but
it's also the configuration with the
fewest number of jobs returned now if
you flip these and have enable
broadening set to true and disable
keyword match set to false you'll get
maximum number of jobs returned for a
search the most relevant jobs will be
followed by keyword matched and expanded
query jobs finally if both disabled
keyword match and enable broadening are
set to true search queries will return
the most relevant jobs followed by only
the expanded query results so you can
see how these two properties can be used
to influence jobs that get returned from
a search query there's no right or wrong
configuration it just depends on what
makes the most sense for your business
case we recommend trying a few different
configurations to see which works best
for you and your users now that we've
covered those two parameters let's look
at two more options you can use to
further refine the jobs that show up in
your users searches will look at
featured jobs and custom ranking in the
next video thanks for watching and
remember when looking for talent it's
okay to keep your head in the cloud